alors je me penche pour prendre ces
derniers mots qu'est-ce que tu veux mon
chéri je suis désolé de te le faire
répéter mais je comprends pas ce que tu
veux dis-moi ce que tu veux mon amour un
blood email
puisqu'il aimait c'était picolé et
bouffé moi je l'ai connu à L'Express
attends quand j'ai connu rebelle quand
il diriger L'Express il allait de bureau
en bureau pour faire ses mini
conférences de relax et il y avait un
mec qui le suivait avec un comme un
chariot roulant comme un chariot de
petit déjeuner avec toutes les
bouteilles et Revel ça c'est le chariot
se garer là et il choisissait tel Pinart
c'est incroyable c'était comme la
perfusion c'est un peu comme un drogué
qui aurait été sur place on lui avait
dit si vous continuez à boire vous
pourrez pas vivre six mois quand on est
sorti de l'hôpital on est rentré à la
maison et avant de monter on a une
brasserie en bas de chez moi il est
arrivé il a dit deux couples non la
bouteille faut fêter ça il me dit et il
a bu jusqu'au bout il aimait ça quoi
mais attends je vais raconter je te l'ai
déjà raconté
à la fin il parlait très mal tu vois il
était vraiment très très mourant
essayez de me dire des choses
[Musique]
pour prendre ces derniers mots qu'est-ce
que tu veux mon chéri je suis désolé de
te le faire répéter mais je comprends
pas ce que tu veux dis-moi ce que tu
veux mon amour un blood email
mais en général les les personnes qui
aiment manger boire etc les vrais
plaisir de la vie aime aussi le cul non
pas du tout
c'est différent
tu dois choisir entre la baguette et le
Beaujolais tu vois ce que je veux dire
donc Thierry quel est ton choix après la
braguette
je pense que ça doit être terrible pour
un homme de
Jean-François merci merci c'est pas le
moment c'est pas le moment c'est pas le
moment de déconner on veut baiser encore
un peu macho
enfin moi je l'ai eu comme directeur à
l'extrême
et c'était un très très bon directeur
intelligent
sachons reconnaître les qualités des
gens ce qui est agréable et pas du tout
avoir des petites mafia
elle a commencé à faire parce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure quand tu as vécu
parler de nos parents quand tu as vécu
50 ans comme mon père et ma mère moi
c'est la moitié qui ment tu se
retrouvait quand tu as été un couple
pendant 43 ans que moi je suis tout seul
c'est très très performant très très
terrible
ce qui est intéressant c'est de savoir
quels sont les recettes des uns et des
autres pour être heureux après tant
d'années c'est ça après tant d'années ah
oui comment fait-on pour continuer à
être heureux et pas sans rien après la
mort de son
aujourd'hui et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu